we're still the surface area and volume
topic there so stepping back a little
bit through shapes that exists in 3d
we're gonna talk about where you're
going to get to 3d shapes again but to
simplify things we're gonna look at two
named shapes like the one that we did in
the first review question today to start
off with we need to remember what do we
talk about what specifically are we
meaning when we say two shapes are
similar in anyone want a venture like a
nice succinct one sentence definition
similar figures are any cake is blown
what do you think similar figures ah
same measurements okay now measurements
are really read employers see I'm gonna
bring in these measurements in a bit
okay but actually similar is quite
different to the same Daniel what would
you alright so really like this when it
is struggling to like what is something
an example is very helpful so I think
the words that Daniel said which was
really helpful were enlarge or shrink
I'll come back to those words in a
second does anyone it's adds something
they feel hasn't been said by the
definition it's already ugly I have to
same properties okay now properties is
another that asked a few more question
but you might say like you know if sides
are parallel in a shape then if you've
got another shape that a similar decides
better still be parallel do you agree
like that's a property does any want to
add anything else to that role yeah ah
okay so now we say you get some more
technical language here of ratios let's
all write a definition
similar figures let's have a definition
similar figures are shapes that share
and I'm going to try and capture all of
the things that we've just mentioned
right so I'm going to say say shapes
that share all characteristics all
characteristics and that includes
properties it includes ratios includes
angles all characteristics accepts sighs
okay now what that gets that is what
Daniel was saying which is that you can
take a shape you can make it really
really big or really really tiny but so
long as the characteristics of the same
the square is still a square the
triangles still pointing in the same
direction whatever as long as it's
sharing though this he'll be similar you
can change the set asides make it one if
you like
now in fact Daniel it make a good maths
teacher I'm gonna take this exact shape
than we did in question one this is the
reason why I introduced it and I'd like
to draw underneath this heading of area
of single fuse I want you to draw
another one that is similar to it but I
want to change the measurements okay so
this time I'm going to draw another
rectangle I know that it looks exactly
the same as the one that I've just drawn
even in terms of sine or maybe something
oh yeah thank you it's still rectangular
ish but that's because on a page we
don't really worry about like we're
setting up to scale right so I'm gonna
put some measurements on this that will
change
let's take this suggestion which was I'm
going to take all the measurements and
I'm going to Domino okay I'm gonna
double all the measurements so this is
no longer seven it's now or take we
worked out the world already point out
the width you used to be 24 so now it's
gonna make that be 48 now I'm gonna put
one more thing on here just to add an
even for interest I provided you a
diagonal right so what will the diet
will be now okay stay with me today
alright now having all of these
measurements here I can now very quickly
work out the area the area is going to
be 14 that's the height times 48 which
is the breadth of the width or whichever
words you choose right
14 times 48 anyone got a number for me
14 6 7 ok now everyone put your pens
down
and I want you to can't believe what
just done
hey pens down look up because this is
kind of the critical point
what have we done we have double with
all of the dimensions right
why should say we've doubled all of the
lakes trying to double hype double the
width of the diagonal okay what you have
a look at the areas the areas have not
doubled
why haven't they doubled maybe I should
possibly push before that how much happy
have they gotten bigger not double but
yeah for size bigger than quadruple okay
now this is the more important question
to ask too early
why has the area quadrupled rather than
doubled if we doubled everything else
why didn't the area double as well sorry
what do you think okay so I've doubled
pause on this per second I'll come to
you in a minute I've doubled here and
I've doubled here so that's doubling
twice right the hold on a second
remember I asked you for the diagonal as
well didn't I double that as well why am
i got doubled three times why is it not
8 hmm I'm getting an important yeah okay
you're you're on the right track
I'm Ryan y'know what do you reckon so
you can have a water measurements on a
shame right but do you remember I mean a
step that is before this they're almost
none of us have written is that the area
is length times breath right two
measurements are required because it's a
two-dimensional shape do you agree yeah
so since two dimensions are required you
double each of those double double and
that's quadruple sarsen right so even
though there's another measurement
that's been doubled it's not relevant
okay I can work this out in terms of
doubling what's doubling twice so in
total two times two is four
does that make sense
okay so here's the way we would for
these things for our example rectangle
if the the weather merely said performed
of ratio if the ratio of lengths from
how first rectangle to our second
rectangle is 7 to 14 24 to 48 25 to 50
in summary it's 1 to 2 then what happens
is the ratio of areas it actually
becomes everything squared so it's
actually 1 squared - 2 squared ok which
as you noticed before is 1 to 4 does
that make sense so you double the length
you're gonna quadruple the areas all
right
how about this what if we made it one
and a half times bigger all of the
measurements so this is 7 right now
suppose we changed it and we made it one
and a half times bigger is 10 and a half
yeah this is 24 so what an apartheid
thing would be 36 pause for a second
think what do you predict will happen
yeah one and a half one and a half a
reasonable conclusion to draw is hey
last time I was two and two and two plus
two is four which is in that in FEMA in
fact what we got okay so is this gonna
be three times bigger because it's one
and a half and one in a heart well in
your work out can you tell me what 2.5
times 36 is
someone got another for me 378 is this
number three times bigger than this it's
not in fact I can tell you right now you
can confirm this for me I believe it's
two and a quarter times bigger it is
this times tuna caught up gives this now
the question is how did I know that a
puffle my math name is Little Miss okay
I didn't you know calculate that
beforehand where did it come from
so 1/2 bigger top times bigger each time
one and a half not plus one and a half
area isn't about addition area is about
multiplication so the 1/2 is multiplied
by one and a half square one and a half
I happen to know is - okay so the ratio
of areas
everything gets squared don't add you
square okay my if I make it seven times
bigger then it would be one squared - 7
squared which is 49 okay and so that's
all there is really to it